voilà une affaire qui soulève une vive
polémique l'histoire un agriculteurs en
colère qui face à l'inaction général a
décidé de se faire justice soi même ce
fait divers se déroule à ambrières dans
la marne jean louis leroux un
agriculteur de la région a été placé en
détention provisoire pour tentative
d'homicide volontaire après avoir tiré
délibérément sur un homme qui tentait de
le cambrioler touché à l'intestin et aux
colons le pronostic vital de la victime
un jeune homme de 19 ans n'est pas
engagé mais il devrait conserver des
séquelles à vie le cambrioleur aurait
essayé de lui voler du carburant dans
son hangar un vol qui serait le 40e 50e
et qui malgré les nombreuses plein de
l'exploitant n'aurait jamais pu être
stoppée c'est la raison pour laquelle
hors de lui l'homme se serait emparé de
son fusil bien décidé à mettre fin à ces
vols de nombreux exploitants agricoles
ont décidé de lancer des marchands
soutien à jean louis leroux pour eux les
agriculteurs sont isolés de tout et les
gendarmes ne sont pas en mesure de les
protéger contre le vol de leur fioul de
leur matériel de travail et parfois même
de leurs bêtes et vous comprenez vous ce
geste alors il ya des agriculteurs qui
ont fait une marche de soutien à jean
louis leroux maître gérard chemla vous
êtes avec nous vous êtes l'avocat de
jean-louis l'eau donc cet agriculteur
vous est ce que vous comprenez le geste
de cet agriculteur qui a tiré sur un
cambrioleur de 19 ans je vous le dit
voilà il dit voilà je vous le dis qu'il
est aujourd'hui c'est vrai que il a un
petit peu inquiet pour le jeune homme en
a qui croient qu'il regrette son geste
vosges il vous n'êtes pas vous ne
comprenez pas que j'ai simplement parce
qu'il est mis en examen quand même pour
tentative d'homicide volontaire donc
cesser on ne peut pas se faire justice
soi-même voilà ma position mais non là
je comprends sa problématique et avait
eu 40 agressions ou trente sept mille
litres de carburant volé il était à bout
et dit lui-même qu'il a paniqué mais je
ne peux pas validé non je ne comprends
pas ce geste le oui quand on dit ah oui
c'est pas qu'on valide lui basse et
comprenez vous songez vous la question
reste dans mon coin je valide comprend
la vessie par an mais à la place deux
mois je suis pas du tout pour le fait
qu'on ait des armes à feu à la maison
parce que ça évite justement ce genre de
malheureusement de gestes parce que si
tu as une arme à feu et que ça fait
quarante fois mais la 41e fois tu tires
donc c'est pour ça mais mais évidemment
qu'on peut comprendre la lassitude
l'agacement le fait que tu vas 40 x à la
gendarmerie pour dire que ça fait face
avec quarante fois que tu es dévalisé
cambrioler que tu as peur pour tous pour
toi et ta famille voilà c'est alors
évidemment que ça veut pas dire qu'on
légitime et qu on dit bravo à ce
monsieur on dit juste qu'on peut se
mettre à sa place alors
rappeler les faits pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent sur ces huit tours dans la
part laissée voilà il ajouté que vous
réagissez énormément sur les réseaux sur
cette affaire les faits se sont déroulés
dans la nuit du 31 janvier au 1er
février peu avant deux heures du matin
trois individus ont pénétré sur la
propriété de jean louis le rond pour lui
voler du carburant
jean louis leroy avait d'abord alerté
les gendarmes après avoir repéré des
voleurs de carburant sur son
exploitation
il explique qu'il a voulu retenir les
voleurs en attendant les gendarmes il a
tiré une fois au sol puis à hauteur de
hanche
la veille jean louis l'euro avait déjà
subi un vol la gendarmerie se trouvant à
25 km de son exploitation était arrivé
trop tard pour arrêter les voleurs à
leur arrivée les gendarmes ont trouvé la
victime donc blessé dans sa voiture il
ces dernières années jean lui avait été
victime d'une quarantaine de vols de ce
type radar acteurs et avait déposé une
trentaine de plaintes
on lui aurait volé près de 7000 litres
de carburant isabelle alors à bord qu'on
est très bien fait votre résumé
légalement ces fausses qui sont isolés
ils sont maltraités ou mal compris par
l'ensemble des gens ils sont pas riches
et tout est constamment effectivement
ils sont ils sont volés moi je j'ai des
agriculteurs dans mon secteur qui vivent
exactement la même chose et qui dit je
suis prêt effectivement à sortir mon
fusil parce que certains sont chasseurs
et ont une arme chez eux pour cette
raison et que ne peut pas on peut pas ne
pas les comprendre honnêtement même si
évidemment on rencontre le geste
regrettable
bernard non mais là il ya une opposition
qui est très forte entre le sentiment de
se rendre justice parce qu'au bout d'un
an on en a ras-le-bol et en tirent
dessus c'est regrettable bien sûr il
doit le regretter évidemment mais il ya
aussi le raisonnement judiciaire parce
qu'évidemment on n'a pas le droit de
tirer sur qui que ce soit et on n'a pas
le droit d'utiliser la violence
j'ai raison m ou pas et les jeudis
briffaud ça appartient aux parties en
parfait ça commence bien
jean-michel dire à établir oui moi
franchement je mets dans sa tête parce
qu'il n'y a qu'une personne qui a été
autant victime de harcèlement de
d'agression de vol etc qui peut réagir
comme ça je le comprends franchement un
bon appartement d'asnières lamche soit
façon elle finit toujours par servir
donc franchement eh bien on arrive dans
un pays quand même celles victimes qui
m'attend qui est condamné à la place de
des voleurs comme ça alors alors on va
rappeler la victime c'est un jeune homme
de 19 ans il a été touché à l'intestin
et aux colons par le tir de jean louis
ses jours ne sont plus en danger mais il
est toujours dans le coma et risque
d'avoir des séquelles à vie
benjamins 1er nous prêtait privé
quand fois combien lui vaut les jeux
c'est lui je mets qui une fois on l'a
une fois par terre après tirent dessus
c'est terrible pour le pour le nomme
enfin il est quand même volé il est
bonne et que cinquante fois je comprends
qu'ils soient excédés et vous dis
franchement moi c'est quelqu'un rentre
chez moi n'ont pas cessé 6% pour me bats
je vais je voulais moi aussi on vient
chez moi comme un fou qu'on me colle et
comment il voit il comme nas ma famille
je ferais exactement la même chose
absolument l'origine c'est pas un oeil
pour oeil dent pour dent à la société
civilisée il ya des codes il ya des lois
d'ailleurs il est mis en examen
il a été libéré ok mais on ne peut pas
réagir vous dites on vient de voler je
tire mais non c'est pas comme ça la
société si non alors il ya plus de
règles mais non je suis désolé non il
pour lui dans pendant c'est le plus gros
progrès de la justice de 8 à lyon avant
quand tu reçois en 2000 claque le mec le
massacre et maintenant tout prend une
claque pour sturm une claque
c'est sympa jean-michel justicia les
forces de police agit là dessus berne
après se faire justice soi même
ces cas là c'est l'anarchie et le chaos
parce qu'ils mais on peut comprendre le
comportement de monsieur en revanche
d'après nos informations les gendarmes
ont tenu à protéger le tireur parce
qu'il paraîtrait que ces trois personnes
là sont des gens du voyage qui voulait
très vite ça se venger alors on va les y
alors m gérard chemla vous êtes l'avocat
de jean louis leroux vous êtes satisfait
de sa libération déjà bien sûr j'ai tout
fait ce tout fait pour ça mais déjà ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que il n'a
pas voulu se faire justice
d'accord il a été averti au milieu de la
nuit que des voleurs étaient là et il a
appelé les gendarmes
le problème c'est que le temps que les
gendarmes arrivent les voleurs ne sont
plus là et donc il s'est dit je vais les
retenir
est ce qu'il a fait c'est qu'il essaie
de retenir et c'est dans cette manoeuvre
là qu'à un moment un des voleurs a couru
vers lui qu'il a tiré un coup de feu
vers le sol et le deuxième couture c'est
pourquoi ils accourent vers lui mais
pour s'enfuir parce qu'il avait allumé
une lumière et qu'il leur a dit arrêtez
arrêtez lui a voulu l'airé les retenir
et ont voulu sauver
donc il a tiré un coup de feu vers le
sol il m'a dit s'arrêter il ne s'est pas
arrêtée on est dans le noir à cet
endroit là et puis vous avez le voleur
qui courent et le deuxième coup de fil
au maître tir et un tout petit peu plus
haut mais il n'a pas visé
et pour tuer on n'est pas du tfc contre
instants alors que j'ai plein de
questions à vous poser il ya plein de
gens qui posent des questions sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est vrai que cette
histoire vous a passionné oui fanny vous
les posez la question à m est ce que
dans ce cas il s'agit d'une légitime
défense dans ça la question
alors c'est différent ils vont discuter
dans criminal en fait il ya un texte du
code de procédure qui dit que toute
personne peut arrêter un voleur ou un
criminel en flagrant délit et donc c'est
prévu par la loi
il a essayé de l'arrêter et son but
c'était simplement que les gendarmes
ariz c'est tout le problème c'est quand
on est à la campagne des gendarmes y met
un quart d'heure vingt minutes une demi
heure pour arriver et jusque là chaque
fois il est arrivé trop tard on n'a pas
eu la vie de maxime sur cette affaire
prendra deux mois je crois que c'est la
légine défense à bâtiment il ya commune
est une intégrité physique
tu peux être touchés moi j'ai une
question est ce que dans ce genre de cas
est ce que le monsieur aurait pu
installer des pièges dans sa maison et
si les coûts ryanair avait été blessé
qu'il aurait bien un truc bien et va
mettre fromage ta demande et on a la
vida tu dis que c'est à dire je
répondais même pas mettre si cette
personne a tiré sur chaque couleur
volontairement moi je pense que c'est
involontaire le fait de tirer sur ces
personnes parce qu'à la fin on contrôle
plus son cerveau on pète les plombs le
monsieur était sûrement burn out parce
qu'il en avait marre et je pense que
juste il avait la peur aussi et du coup
je pense pas que ce soit volontaire je
pense que c'est involontaire
alors aujourd'hui contre concrètement
qu'est ce qui va se passer pour monsieur
law alors déjà il va pas rentrer chez
lui
d'accord donc là et quand il valait où
là il va aller quelque part je vais pas
vous dire où d'accord de façon à ne pas
être confronté avec les voleurs d'accord
qui ait pas de risque pour personne
d'accord donc qui va se retrouver dans
un endroit où il va essayer de
travailler un petit peu de surveiller sa
ferme à distance pour que les choses ne
le ruine pas complètement
et puis ensuite il a une protection pas
du tout dans sa ferme ou dans pas du
tout alors je ne sais pas précisément
mais lui ne va pas être protégé
simplement qu'on va laisser discret et
sur une exploitation va être surveillé
ou pas du tout peut-être quelques temps
je l'espère en tous les accords alors
pourquoi il a été placé en détention
je me demande il était placé en
détention avec un certain nombre
d'arguments
les deux arguments les plus forts
c'était pour le protéger d'accord et à
cause du trouble à l'ordre public et le
protéger c'est extraordinaire parce que
c'est quelqu'un pendant cinq ans on n'a
pas réussi à le protéger la seule
protection qu'on lui propose à la fin
c'est de le mettre en prison
d'accord voilà c'est ça que la cour
d'appel a revu ce matin en disant on va
pas le protéger comme ça et sur le
trouble à l'ordre public
mais il y avait plus de troubles par le
fait de le mettre en prison que par le
fait de libérer
il est dans quel état aujourd'hui
monsieur leroux bas il est comme
quelqu'un qui a tiré sur quelqu'un
d'autre
il est bien clair le jeune homme aime
bien sûr qui dit inquiet il a pris de
ses nouvelles
alors on peut pas de la maison d'arrêt
prendre des nouvelles d'accord
simplement on s'est tenu au courant et
les éléments que la gendarmerie nous a
donné on en a fait notre profit regrette
son geste
bien sûr qu'il ya de son geste après il
a eu aussi le sentiment d'être dans une
situation sans issue
d'accord et pourquoi il a tiré sur sûr
c'est tommy hill était à bout non il
explique qu'à aucun moment il n'a voulu
le toucher accord oui c'est ce qu'il a
voulu le faire s'arrêter et il a tiré
dans le noir dans une direction en ne
pensant pas le toucher d'ailleurs le
jeune homme a continué à courir et à
aucun moment jean louis leroux n'a pensé
qu'il était blessé
c'est les gendarmes qui vont semble
qu'il avait voulu se faire justice lui
même ça du tout pas du tout il n'a pas
du tout on a voulu retenir son voleur
pour que les gendarmes identifient tu
vraiment on est sûrs aux cetc sa version
savait écouter ce sera la version qui a
jusqu'au bout puisque on va un jour ou
l'autre se retrouver devant des juges et
où des jurés et les jurés c'est des gens
comme vous et je suis même pas sûre que
ce jour là il y aura un nom et qui
s'occupe de la ferme pour l'instant in a
new narines de marchands ilan ouvriers
[Applaudissements]
excusez-moi m oui vous avez bien varié
oui parce que dans ces cas difficiles on
vous qu'êtes avocat je crois qu'on peut
plaider
si la riposte on peut vous en sortir
dans ces cas là que si la riposte est
proportionnel au niveau de l'attaqué
bravo c'est vrai alors ça veut dire que
il était en en face ils les croyait
armée pour utiliser de l'huile ne sais
pas s'il est armé
d'accord on est dans le noir il est 1h
45 du matin il ya des personnes qui
courent il ne les connaît pas et il peut
pas savoir si son armée où il faut que
ça alors on va voir ce qu'en pensent les
téléspectateurs voient là parce que ça
vraiment et 4 amélie scoop regardez les
créateurs prennent ce geste c'est
incroyable franchement je pensais pas y
aurait eu un tel résultat
je vous le dis je suis assez étonné en
tout cas merci m chamla d'avoir été avec
nous merci on espère que le jeune homme
va se remettre très vite
et voilà et que monsieur leroux va
pouvoir reprendre
voilà en tout cas va pouvoir gérer son
son activité voilà mais en tout cas
c'est vrai que c'est c'est une sombre
affaire voilà on met 90 10 euros je suis
vraiment étonné du résultat merci
d'avoir été avec moi
[Applaudissements]